there's proven technology
that it's out there now I'm not saying
anything that's extraordinary everybody
has a specific frequency signature
through their voice it's kind of like a
fingerprint there are no two voice
signatures that are alike and so now
with this technology you can pick up the
frequency of your voice to actually they
use it in a medical field to see where
you have imbalances they can see cancer
markers they can see all kinds of
without blood tests or anything just
through your voice like it would just
reflect back to me the frequency you
know the frequency the heart or this or
the stomach or digestive system or
things like that it can be very specific
to even tell you what vitamins you need
even like like
imbalances basically minerals
so if you understand that the frequency
is being embedded in your voice and of
course it's going to change every day
because you are different every day then
you can embed you could be in this
incredible State of Consciousness again
through training
and if I am and in fact we did this
experiment if you don't mind me sharing
yeah so so I was working with these guys
actually in their lab and I said I want
to know what my meditation actually does
like I mean I know what it does to me
but I want to like see it visually I
want my biology you want markers markers
I want metrics like I want data you know
so we did this experiment where we did
it through the voice we were measuring
the frequency of the voice but we also
had uh the EEG you know okay cool
picking up a skull cap that you know
wears all the electrodes that shows the
shows your sort of neuro neural activity
right right exactly and so so I sat down
uh so I started doing my the the
meditation that I call connecting to
Source because I know that frequency I
live that frequency like I said so I
know where where it is but you know or
they yeah it's like what whatever I'll
just say source and I'll get there well
that was that's what I was trying to to
Pro I mean to demonstrate so as I'm
going through this exercise and I'm just
meditating and saying the second
I would say
Source or I would say I'm connecting to
social whatever my meditation is I would
go to that frequency because I have
lived it I've done it I know where my
Consciousness where my brain goes it's a
very specific frequency
so I would go there as I'm saying it
the second I would say that my Alpha
Waves were like I don't know just like
jump
and my brain would start to become
completely coherent
specifically with certain words and
certain tones
and then by the end of it
your your whole i i in fact it's I think
it's on my Facebook I'm not sure but
there's those images of the brain where
when you start and how you end
everything is perfectly like coherent
like the colors the organizations are
symmetrical from left to right yes where
it's activated yes instead of like right
and left and blah blah blah blob here a
blob there yeah and what was fascinating
is the second I would say the word it
would go up because that was
energetically
bringing it through the voice it was the
frequency
so I was like boom this is proof that
it's not I love that you get scientific
I love I love that because it's like you
know I want to show that it's real yeah
but then my friend she's doing some
other meditation or something and her
her chart was nice I mean it was it was
different it was just nice and then she
does
my meditation she listens to mine and
her brain does what mine did I've always
said that the like I think that truth
holds a frequency I think the reason why
you like someone or you resonate with a
song or whatever that may be is because
the more in truth they are the more you
resonate with that frequency like
there's a it's like a very it's like a
feel-good frequency that seeps into you
so and it just resonates like truth
resonates with truth and so your inner
being your higher self wants more of
that the more truth the better and so
connecting with that with people whether
they're on someone on TV or someone in
your life or a relationship or a song
that you listen to like you're
resonating with the truth and you're
saying you've got the science to prove
that when you're connected energetically
to a truth that you have and an emotion
and creating an emotion and energy with
it you tap into a frequency and you
transmit it
exactly you broadcast it so that was
incred that was like yes and so this is
because people say oh I don't need this
meditation I meditate or I yes but
everybody can say Source everybody can
say but that's not what we're talking
about we're talking about a specific
frequency delivered in a certain way
that then your brain recognizes and then
it can find it on its own that's the
idea but I think this was also we were
talking about the average person you
know having to like think that they need
the discipline or the time you know it's
more about really uh finding the right
energy how does your exploration into
space and I've watched a tear in the sky
what role does an extraterrestrial and
knowing that there's other life out
there what role does that play then why
is that important a lot of it has to do
with me uh trying to bring the truth
that it's more than hey you know the
gray aliens are here to invade our
planet and Destroy and there is so much
more that is out there that people don't
you know know about and so I use these
films
always try to bring science as well
maybe you've learned more about what it
was that you guys saw in the sky that
looked like it was like the clouds
parted and there was little particles or
little dots and one appearing and then
it kind of clouded over what have you
found well first of all we were there
only five days and yes it's true we had
an incredible I mean hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of equipment
you know from Optical equipment to
infrared to you know flare cameras which
is like military grade uh to radiation I
mean all sorts of things we were in
three locations like you said but still
we are civilians right and in five days
five days we captured like hundreds of
hours of data
so and very anomalous things so for
example
um you know things that kind of would
show up like make a U-turn and leave
things that would appear in the middle
of the screen rotate and then like
disappear the government's telling us
right now like we don't know we don't
have data it's like okay but we're
civilians we went out and we did that
but the biggest thing is the one you
mentioned at the end we captured so the
camera gets triggered when there isn't
something that is not a bird it's not a
plane because the the system knows it's
it's none of those things and so
it gets triggered the camera gets
triggered and we have that video and
when we we slowed it down we saw wait
because when it got triggered we
couldn't see anything but then when we
analyzed it we saw that literally it was
some sort of a cloud it opens and closed
and it revealed 50 to 100
uh reflective objects like actual
objects in fact some of them pop out of
the cloud we don't know what you know so
at the same time it correlates with
radar uh radar also picks up exactly
some sort of blob in that exact same
spot uh right we have a a crazy
radiation and gamma ray of like I think
it was 43 or something insane the normal
is like three I mean the first word that
came to mind when I was watching and I
was like it's like a portal you know of
course and then you guys said maybe a
black hole or a wormhole I mean yeah I
mean if it opens and closes it feels
almost like some kind of Wormhole portal
that is like oh this is another galaxy
of some sort and these are all stars in
it but the question is why did it open
these aren't stars because the the radar
doesn't pick up on radiation or light it
picks up on objects like reflective
objects so these were actual objects do
you have a theory on on how
this universe or Beyond
materializes it's definitely a
Multiverse I mean I think there's an
infinite number of universes but not in
the way people think like you know how
people think that oh there's another one
of you in another Universe doing the
same thing like a parallel universe to
me that doesn't make any sense because
it would be like what's the point why
would you have a bunch of you doing the
same thing so you know I mean creation
is purposeful the idea is there's one of
you doing this here but there's another
aspect of you could be doing something
else for me the universal organization
is more
um planetary systems within Galactic
systems within universes and each
universe is within multiverses it's more
of a of a fractal existence and then you
see the geometry you see perfect
geometry you see the harmonics between
uh the macro and the micro and so but
going to question is this a simulation
so it's interesting because I don't see
it at all as a simulation like it's a
computer uh generated thing and it's all
fake however
I feel we are inside a sort of a network
a network of information which creates
this particular reality that is both
that is part of a larger
uh I don't think it's it's a it's I
think it's more of a divine order that's
my take on it there's a larger Universal
intelligence that is guiding this
now there may be some extraterrestrial
manipulating
you know the reality that we exist in
but they're not the creators this is not
where it ends there's a much larger
Universal organization that is divinely
orchestrated because there's too much
evidence
of divine intelligence you know it's too
much and so
it's at the same time
that a lot of it is pre uh directed like
it's almost like you have a prenatal
contract
to come in here and carry out this
contract and at the same time you are
creating it as you go along meaning you
you create your reality otherwise we'd
just be robots we'll just be machines
like it wouldn't matter what happens to
you because oh it's predestined it's
already part of the computer the
simulation so what's the point why
should I intend uh to to have a house or
to do this if it's if it's pre-ordained
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen